house of the dragon is coming in less
than a year
set
168 years before game of thrones this
targaryen-based prequel show which
focuses on the targaryen civil war known
as the dance of the dragons will
obviously have many similarities with
game of thrones one of which is valyrian
steel swords valyrian steel is a form of
metal that was forged in the days of the
mighty valyrian freehold
when fashioned into bladed weapons the
steel can hold an especially keen edge
remaining sharp forever without the need
for honing
it's confirmed that house of the dragon
will feature three valyrian swords in
season one but a few joining later on in
the show
invented in targaryen's original home
valyria these swords are of unparalleled
quality george rr martin says that if
the two fighters of equal skill and
power met on the field the one with
valerian steel in his hands will win
that's how much of a change it makes
almost all of the legendary warriors of
westeros have builted it what makes
valyrian steel swords so unique is that
it's extremely rare and its blades are
lighter stronger and sharper in
comparison to ordinary steel valyrian
still possibly formed with dragons and
definitely forged with magic and spells
was manufactured in valyrian freehold of
old
according to legend valyrian steel was
made with dragonfire and infused with
magical spells
some say with blood magic literally
requiring fire and blood like house
targaryen's mota
after the doom of valyria just as old
valyrians send their dragons except
targaryens and their dragons all was
destroyed
including the secret of making the
valyrian steel
valyrian steel was always costly but it
became considerably more so when there
was no more valyria the secret of its
making lost with the doom
only the greatest weaponsmiths can
reforge swords from existing valyrian
steel
making those remaining weapons highly
treasured and extremely rare however
there are still plenty of them in
westeros and especially in this time
period of the targaryen civil war which
includes the two the targaryens owned
which we never had the opportunity to
see in game of thrones as they got lost
in meantime so let's see which 3
valyrian swords will house of the dragon
feature in season 1 and which will join
in the later seasons targaryen's
blackfyre and dark's sister along with
stark sights are the three valyrian
steel swords we'll see in season 1
orphan maker lamentation vigilance and
lady forlorn are the names of the
remaining valyrian swords that will
appear by the end of the series
let's start with the most famous of them
all and possibly the most legendary of
them all house targaryens blackfyre
blackfyre is a valyrian steel sword that
originally belonged to aegon the first
targaryen
blackfyre is a fabled hand and a half
long sword of valyrian steel once
fielded by aegon to conquer during the
targaryen conquest of the seven kingdoms
afterward it became the treasure the
ancestral blade of house targaryen
carried by kings and princes
during the story of house of the dragon
and therefore during the targaryen civil
war it belonged to aegon ii
aegon ii targaryen's possession of
blackfyre enhanced his legitimacy
against his rival rhaenyra targaryen
during the dance of the dragons
before and after this blackfyre was
wielded by many great warriors and no
doubt seeing such a legendary sword will
be amazing
coming as the second valyrian sword
we'll see in season 1 is also from house
targaryen and as you've probably guessed
it by now it's dark's sister the dark
sister is the name of the famous
longsword of valyrian steel once
belonging to visenya targaryen the
sister wife of aegon the conqueror a
great warrior she used it in battle as
well as riding her dragon during the war
of conquest
in our story it's used by another
legendary warrior prince named daemon
targaryen
prince daemon targaryen was given dark
sister by king jaehaerys the first for
his prowess
sir kristen cole defeated daemon in
attorney for king viserys the first
ascension
knocking dark's sister from the prince's
hand with a morning star daemon wields
dark sister during his war for her
stepstones
in 115 ac he defeats the borrows
betrothed of lena valerian with the
blade in a duel
during the dance of the dragons and
during one of the most epic fights in
westerosi history daemon fights against
aemond targaryen with the blade in the
battle above the god's eye
leaping from the back of his dragon
characters to plunge dark's sister into
aemon's eye venaemon's bones were found
some years later in the waters of the
god's eye dark sister was still thrust
healed deep through his eye socket
cannot help but think of this demon
statement that's written in fire and
blood book dark's sister was made for
nobler tasks than slaughtering sheep she
has a thirst for blood demon targaryen
to cordless valerian
the third and final valyrian steel sword
will see in season one of house of the
dragon
is the one you've already seen in game
of thrones
it's how stark's ancestral great sword
dies
it's as wide across as a man's hand and
six feet long and taller even than
romp's dark
the blade is valyrian steel spell forged
and dark as smoke with deep rippling
the name ice is a legacy from the age of
heroes and predates the current sword
about 400 years before king robert the
first baratheon's reign
the valyrian steel greatsword was spell
forged in valyria and acquired by house
stark
who named it after that legacy
during house of the dragon it's fielded
by legendary craig stark who supports
rhaenyra targaryen and marches south to
support her claim
lord craig and stark will use ice to
behead all the traitors when he arrives
in king's landing time in the capital
which became known as the hour of the
wolf
lord stark will also use it in his fight
against aim on the dragonite who is said
to be house targaryen's finest warrior
and about whom you still hear songs all
over westeros
those are the three we will see in
season 1 but later seasons will feature
many more of them
one of them is lamentation a famed
valyrian steel sword that belongs to
house royce
sir william royce fields the blade
during the dance of the dragons
the sword is torn from the hand of
willem however when he is killed during
the ride of the seven
with willem's death the sword is carried
off
never to be found again however some
rumors claim that sir warrick wheaton
slashed a wing off of xyrex with a
valyrian steel sword likely lamentation
during the storming of the dragonpit
next sword that will appear later on is
vigilance
this valyrian steel long sword belongs
to house hightower lord dormund
hightower wields the blade during the
targaryen civil war fighting for king
aegon ii
after the battle on the honey vine he
used it to knight his squire the king's
brother prince theron
dubbing him sir there on the daring for
turning the battle in his favor with his
dragon thesarian lord dormund is killed
by roddy the ruin leader of stark silly
tarmy winter wolves at the battle of
templeton
it's unknown what happened to vigilance
afterward another sword we'll see later
on is orphan maker a valyrian steel long
sword with a black blade belonging to
house roxnet
sir john roxton wields the blade during
the dance of the dragons while fighting
for king aegon the second targaryen and
the greens
during the battle in the honeymine he
used it to deliver a fatal wound to
lordove and costane during the second
battle of tumbleton john slew hugh
hammer with orphan maker splitting him
from groin to throat shortly thereafter
he was killed by hughes men in a ten
against one fight the sword came into a
possession of lordanwin peak
when pig became hand of the king during
the regency of young king aegon iii
targaryen in 133 ac
he drew orphan maker declaring that's
unlike the previous hand the blind and
crippled sir thailand lannister he could
still will the sword the sword's current
whereabouts are unknown the final and
one of the most legendary valyrian steel
swords in westeros that we'll see is
lady forlorn
it's the ancestral longsword of house
corbrey
lady forlorn is traditionally passed
down from lord to lord but examples of
lords lending the blade to a son or a
brother for their lifetime only to have
it returned to the lord afterward have
been recorded in the history of the
house
lady forlorn has a heart-shaped ruby in
its pommel its valyrian steel is smoke
grey in appearance
the name lady forlorn is a legacy from
the coming of the andals
and predates the current sword
robar the second royce the high king of
the first men of the vale
claimed the first lady forlorn after
slaying kwail corbray the king of the
fingers and the andal leader
robar wielded lady forlorn during the
battle the seven stars
using it to kill tor gold toilet and a
decoy dressed as sir are the serene the
coral braves claimed that sir jamie
corbrey slew robar in the battle
allowing them to reclaim the first lady
forlorn
at some point the coral brace acquired
the valyrian steel sword which they
named lady forlorn in honor of the
ancient sword sir corbin corbray the
brother of lord lillian corbrey wields
lady forlorn during the dance of the
dragons corbin one of the regions for
aegon iii it's laid by a crossbowman at
runestone after drawing lady forlorn on
lord ganthur royce those are all the
valyrian steel swords that we'll see in
the house of the dragon the most
legendary of them ice blackfyre and dark
sister you'll see in season 1 with
others coming and going throughout the
series
the game of thrones prequel series house
of the dragon based on the book fire and
blood velar in 2022 on hbo thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one peace